restrictions à l'égard des femmes
manifestations interdites appel à la
résistance du fils massoud concrètement
comment lutter contre la volonté
aujourd'hui des talibans peut-on compter
sur une nouvelle forme de résistance
notamment en héritage de celui que l'on
surnommé le lion du panchir ou est-ce
peine perdue c'est l'objet de notre
décryptage ce soir
est avec nous pour en parler régis le
sommier grand reporter rt france bons
soient régis à vos côtés salvatore
lombardo écrivain vous êtes l'auteur de
massoud à massoud ça vient de paraître
aux éditions marei merci également de
votre présence ce soir justement il ya
20 ans on en parlait le commandant
massoud était assassiné aujourd'hui
régis le sommier la question qu'on se
pose c'est que représentent-ils
exactement dans l'afghanistan
d'aujourd'hui est ce le héros national
comme on nous le présente souvent vous
qui avez passé encore une fois un le
mois de juillet sur place a alors le
commandant massoud reste une figure
emblématique populaire chez les tadjik
qui représente à peu près 30% de la
population au delà aussi il a une aura
dans d'autres compartiments de la
société
ça reste oui une figure importante en
afghanistan mais on peut pas comprendre
l'afghanistan si on comprend pas la
donne ethnique et la donne tribales et
il est évident que dans d'autres ethnies
le commandant massoud n'a pas la
popularité qui peut avoir chez les siens
en particulier chez les hasards à
massoud a été un seigneur de guerre
quand on est un seigneur de guerre en
afghanistan
évidemment on fait la guerre donc on
n'est pas quelqu'un c'est pas un
démocrate entre guillemets à
l'européenne et il a laissé certains
mauvais souvenir pendant ses conquêtes
et pendant toute là la période où
l'instabilité s'était installé en
afghanistan où me diraient les lâcher un
moment mais la guerre civile afghane a
été terrible il y avait trois seigneurs
de guerre principaux qui se partageaient
le pays massoud de ce tome et hekmatyar
et ils se sont fait la guerre parfois
ils ont fait des alliances et tout ça ça
a été quand même eu sur le dos du peuple
afghan et les talibans ont profité
justement de ses divisions de cette
époque là pour arriver au pouvoir donc
voilà le commandant massoud oui très
populaire chez certains au nid par
d'autres aujourd'hui clairement
salvatore lombardo c'est son fils ahmad
qui a repris qui tente en tout cas de
reprendre avec difficulté certes la
résistance vous voyez beaucoup de
différences entre le père et le fils
en dehors de là je ne vois pas de
différence l'unique différence c'est que
ahmad interne la nouvelle génération
afghane vous savez vingt années on
passait votre spécialiste
disait que massoud c'était il ya vingt
ans que les hasards à etc accessoirement
je m'inscris info pour pas mal de choses
les hasards à faisait partie de la garde
personnelle du commandant massoud il est
réhabilité l'ethnie hazara et il l'aura
de redonner une fierté les hazaras a
créé quelques
ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est un
commandant un seigneur de guerre quand
on est un seigneur de guerre en
afghanistan n'est pas quelqu'un de bleu
blanc comme on a pu le présenter et un
certain nombre de populations moi j'ai
passé du temps chez les hazara en
février dernier des tests commandant
massoud voilà c'est tout un temps où les
a alors roulé dans certaines pas tous
mais ce que j'ai rencontrés sur le franc
atteint locales sous les bombardements
des talibans des hasards acquis protéger
tout ce qu'il pouvait
aucun portrait du commandant massoud
suis désolé vous l'avez dans certains
coûts demeurent à dasht el basri pareil
donc cesser reconnaissez que la
l'afghanistan est quand même un pays
divisé ethniquement ou les zones
tribales compte avant tout et que cette
vision démocratique où je ne dis pas la
colle à la personnalité du commandant
massoud a dépassé sa communauté sa joue
je vous précède de très bien relancer
des plages est une réalité mais avait
rien moins qu un cd c'est une réalité on
verra a souhaité redonner c'est que le
commandant massoud s'est comporté
parfois comme les autres seigneurs de
guerre pour la cto cdc des gens qui ont
ils à dieu il a il a détruit une partie
de kaboul voilà dans son affrontement et
quelques matières donc tous tous à ccc
alors c'est intéressant mais c'est vrai
que c'est intéressant parce que ça c'est
un disco pour le coup on n'entendra
jamais sur une autre chaîne qu'ici parce
que c'est vrai que il est présenté le
commandant massoud certainement à bien
des égards à juste titre comme un héros
national
qui assure la démocratie
sur le terrain il ya une forme de
controverse parce que la population la
diversité gammées et grandes
c'est ça ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
cette analyse
l'analyse l'analyse ethnique c'est une
réalité les dix les différents chefs de
guerre c'est une réalité ce n'est pas
une réalité de croire que massoud ne
fait pas l'unanimité d'un dans d'autres
communautés que la sienne il ya même les
pachtouns qui est qu'ils aiment massoud
il ya des pages ciblées
et de la a décrit massoud excusez moi je
vous ai dit c'est parler mais sinon je
suis venu pour parler des sentiments moi
j'ai passé des mois en afghanistan s'est
pas passé j'ai passé des mois il ya deux
jours j'ai passé des mois d'un an
pendant 25 ans de ma vie d'avant gg pas
et j'ai partagé des combats j'étais sous
les bombardements atteint locale la
bataille des batailles a tué des
milliers de votre nom mais je parle déjà
de voir quand je parle de la capacité
pour la presse du temps dans d'autres
ethnies auprès des pachtouns excusez moi
le commandant massoud n'est pas la
figure de référence il n'est pas la
figure de référence chez les hazara il
n'est pas la figure de référence chez
les ouzbeks cc la réalité de
l'afghanistan qui est comme ça vous
savez j avais représente 30% de la
population c'est une ethnie dans la nuit
parce que ce serait occulter
l'importance du combat mené à l'heure
actuelle contre toute attente
charles vient ahmad masood ans ahmad
ahmad masood contre toute attente parce
qu'il est normal de gens que ça gêne et
y compris chez nos confrères chez nos
confrères journalistes ahmad masood ce
n'est pas l'héritier c'est quelqu'un qui
a su créer une vague en l'espace de deux
années il a créé une vague de sympathie
autour de lui chez nouvelle génération
de d'argan parce que pour beaucoup de
gens comme pour beaucoup de jeunes
français de gaulle ils savent pas trop
ce que ça signifie pour de beaucoup de
jeunes cubain che guevara ou camille le
cien fuegos insat à ce que ça signifie
pour beaucoup de jeunes afghans massoud
c'est une figure tutélaire lointaine
espèce de statue du commandeur
entouré de deux nuages médiatique on
sait pas trop
ahmad est arrivé en l'espace de 18 mois
il est arrivé à se constituer un capital
de sympathie pratiquement partout dans
le pays qui est qui est assez
exceptionnel d'après moi d'ailleurs il
est arrivé à fasciner des foules encore
davantage que son père pourquoi
peut-être parce qu'il a un discours plus
modéré peut-être parce qu'il n'est pas
un chef de guerre peut-être parce qu'il
est jeune peut-être parce qu'ils me
proposent d'autres solutions que les
solutions originalement proposé par
santerre mais quoi qu'il en soit il est
dans une immense fidélité à l'héritage
politique de santerre et aujourd'hui il
propose une solution originale qui me
semble parfait parfaitement viable et
qui semble parfaitement n'y a pas
d'autres personnes il ya 48 heures
j'étais dans le cas de la suisse
university à genève pour un symposium
sur l'afghanistan avec mon ami bernard
henri lévy et on partage la même analyse
c'est à dire que ce jeune homme là il
incarne face à l'incohérence des
occidentaux sa salle et une cohérence de
l'asie centrale il impose une figure
romantique baroque et poétique qui peut
qui peut changer la donne réellement
alors en tout cas pour le moment il ne
l'a pas changé il ya eu la chute du
panchir que lui reprochent d'ailleurs
certains anciens combattants de son père
je vous propose d'en écouter avant de
vous faire réagir justement
ahmad masood est un patriote mais il est
jeune et n'a pas l'expérience militaire
de son père la chute du punch ir face
aux talibans si son père était toujours
en vie jamais nous n'aurions vu cela on
va continuer peut-être dans cette
polémique mais sous 2 contres mais ya
pas de polémique entre nous disons nous
le pensions n'est pas tombé complètement
ça c'est une réalité il faut dire aussi
que sans le sens l'appui des
hélicoptères d'attaqué
pakistanais sans l'appui de l'aviation
pakistanaise
sans l'appui des drones fourni
généreusement par la turquie
ça n'aurait pas été possible donc
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à l'époque il
peut se souvenir que les soldats russes
ont pu pénétrer au coeur au coeur du
panchir et mines ils ne sont jamais
parvenus à le conquérir totalement
pourquoi parce que massoud prévoyait des
possibilités de retrait sur des sommes
pratiquement inaccessible il compris
dans des défilés ils accessibles pour
les hélicoptères de combat son fils a
fait exactement la même chose donc des
anciens combattants disent que si
massoud était là dans les mêmes
conditions massoud aurait fait la même
chose que son fils il aurait demandé à
ses troupes de rompre le combat et de se
retirer sur une deuxième voire une
troisième ligne de défense vous savez
massoud avait une parole et vous la
connaissez vous aussi je suis persuadé
ils disent ils préfèrent perdre du
terrain que perdre des hommes
inutilement c'est le même chose pour
ahmad
aujourd'hui régis le sommier clairement
on voit que cette résistance cet appel à
la résistance d'arman massoud mais aussi
sur le terrain avec les manifestations
des uns et des autres y compris des
femmes pénètre entendu avoir un écho
est-ce que tout simplement cette
résistance est ce qu'elle est perdue
d'avancé
aujourd'hui en afghanistan que c'est
plus complexe que ça elle est perdre des
les pas perdus d'avancé ce que ce que
disait ce qui était dit tout à l'heure
c'est c est être tout à fait exact la
l'afghanistan d'aujourd'hui n'est pas
l'afghanistan en 2001 il faut vraiment
insisté sur le fait que kaboul et un
certain nombre de villes même jalalabad
même des 3d des endroits très
conservateurs ont eu taxes ont eu accès
on fonctionne et je dirais pendant 20
ans au diapason du monde à kaboul il ya
eu des je voyais des choses assez christ
l'a tout à l'heure c'est comment ces
peintures murales qui ont été posées par
les talibans juste avant en juillet
quand j étais sûr c'est juste source sur
les murs que vous montriez tout à
l'heure il y avait des peintures de
médecins des peintures de jean
représentant la société civile il avait
même pas un taliban un des fans aux
talibans ce célèbre avec son rpg et ses
yeux verts et à la place du rpg il avait
mis un crayon donc il y avait une sorte
de voile à de vitalité de la société qui
s'exprimait à travers ses pochoirs sur
les murs alors c'est une résistance qui
va pas être tout de suite une résistance
armée mais c'était vie donc là il ya une
opposition fondamentale entre ce que
professent les taliban et on le voit
petit à petit malgré qu il ya de temps
en temps un pas en avant et deux pas en
arrière ou 6000 soulignait tout à
l'heure que y aura peut-être une femme
au gouvernement etc et puis il ya en
même temps il ne peut pas faire de sport
c'est la charia et c'est donc
certainement une résistance en tout cas
des gens éclairés qui vont rester en
afghanistan parce qu'ils n'ont pas le
choix
et a beaucoup moi je connais beaucoup de
gens qui sont encore vraiment très à
risque qui vivent terrés à kaboul parce
qu'ils se sont exprimés parce que on
sait qu'ils ont eu ces opinions là et
que les talibans 2.0 s'ils ont un côté
je dirais progressistes c'est qu'ils
savent très bien comment manier les
réseaux sociaux et qui il observe et ils
ont observé quel journaliste avait fait
quoi etc etc donc ça ils ont vraiment
une observation de cette société donc
comment un mouvement de résistance
alors je termine juste là dessus il ya
quand même un son de cloche que moi j'ai
entendu le à kaboul auprès des
chauffeurs de taxi etc c'est que il ya
une telle lassitude de la guerre que
sépare en deux ans de guerre qu il ya
des gens qui vous disent si l'état libre
en arrive à faire un proche de la paix
on est prêt à aller avec les talibans
c'est 100 et même une fois là c'est
quarante deux ans de guerre
l'afghanistan vous vous posez la
question à des gens ou leur demander
est-ce que vous la paix c'est quoi pour
vous ils savent pas quoi vous dire ils
n'ont jamais connu ça et ça parce que
ces clapets vous restez avec nous s'il
vous plaît messieurs puisqu'un premier
vol 1 c'est aussi ça d'actualité
aujourd'hui a décollé de kaboul vers
l'étranger depuis le retrait américain
d'ailleurs un washington on le souligne
un fait des sites les talibans pour voir
leur coopération à leur flexibilité ce
soir 200 étrangers évacués
on va retrouver justement thomas bonnet
en direct de new-york bonsoir thomas que
pouvez-vous nous dire sur cette
évacuation mené aujourd'hui
et bien 200 personnes ont donc quitté
l'afghanistan à bord d'un avion d'une
compagnie aérienne du qatar c'est le
premier vol vous l'avez dit depuis le
retrait des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan à la fin du mois d'août à
bord de cet appareil des américains mais
aussi des canadiens des allemands ou
encore des hongrois
ce vol a donc quitté kaboul à
destination de doha la capitale du qatar
et au delà du soulagement pour ceux qui
attendaient leur évacuation
d'afghanistan c'est aussi un signe
d'espoir pour une reprise des vols
commerciaux dans le pays d'ailleurs
l'opération a été saluée par la maison
blanche qui a publié un communiqué pour
souligner la coopération et la
flexibilité des talibans considérant
cela comme un premier pas positif
l'envoyé spécial du qatar à kaboul a lui
parlé d'un jour historique tandis que le
responsable technique de l'aéroport se
dit confiant sur le travail mené pour
remettre remettre en état de marche cet
aéroport de kaboul je propose de les
écouter
pour la première fois il va y avoir un
vol international de doha à kaboul c'est
un vol commercial ou charter peu importe
comment vous l'appelez
le point important c'est qu'il aura des
passagers étrangers et locaux qui
voyagent de kaboul à doha et de doha à
leur destination finale
cette partie de l'aéroport où des
techniciens qatari travail est presque
terminée nous serons très contents
lorsqu'ils auront terminé leur travail
si dieu le veut l'aéroport sera prêt
pour des vols normaux rapidement
et thomas c'est dans ce contexte que
vont se dérouler samedi les
commémorations des 20 années du 11
septembre après leur très chaotique de
l'armée américaine d'ailleurs djoubaye
d'année et cibler un à l'occasion de ces
commémorations sa présence n'est pas
toujours souhaitée par certains
oui absolument vous avez les critiques
on va dire attendu de la part de
l'opposition républicaine
et ce qui est un peu plus nouveau c'est
que vous avez aussi des critiques qui
sont formulées ces derniers jours par
des proches de victimes des attentats du
11 septembre je pense notamment à la
soeur du pilote qui a été tué le pilote
qui était au sein de l'appareil qui a
été détournée contre le pentagone et
bien elle a eu des mots très durs contre
joe biden elle reproche au président
américain de laisser l'afghanistan aux
mains des talibans c'est un peu le même
son de cloche chez un certain nombre de
proches de victimes et certains d'entre
eux ont même explicitement demandé à ce
que joe biden n'assiste pas à ses
commémorations samedi que ce soit à new
york ou à washington il faut noter que
ce n'est pas la première fois que des
proches de victimes des attentats du
11-septembre demande à joe biden ne pas
se rendre aux commémorations puisque ces
dernières semaines il y avait eu à des
appels en ce sens de la part d'autres
familles de victimes qui avaient cosigné
une lettre ils sont 1800 et dans cette
lettre il demandait à joe biden doit
faire toute la transparence sur les
différentes enquêtes autour de ces
importantes de ces attentats il reproche
notamment qu'on n'est pas vraiment
d'informations sur le financement et sur
le rôle présupposés de l'arabie saoudite
dans ces attentats du 11 septembre alors
depuis joe biden a indiqué que des
documents allaient être déclassifiés
sans qu'on ne sache réellement à quelles
informations vont être rendus publics
mais en tout cas le contexte et
l'atmosphère est particulièrement lourde
pour le président américain au moment de
commémorer donc c'est décennie depuis
les attentats du 11 septembre merci à
thomas abonné je me tourne vers vos
nouveaux régis le sommier vous avez
aussi été correspondant à washington
plusieurs années c'est vrai que le
timing est vraiment assassin pour joe
biden ce retrait américain et ses
commémorations du 11-septembre tout à
fait parce que pour les américains pas
particulièrement le 11 septembre c'est
les tours les tours qui fument les les
tours dans les ruines et beaucoup
d'américains se souvient de george bush
tu eu le lendemain de deux attentats qui
va rencontrer les pompiers de new york
il ya un pompier qui lui dit on ne vous
entend pas il leur parle et vous ne vous
entend pas monsieur le président et lui
prend un évier faux nez il dit je ferai
en sorte que ceux qui ont fait ça nous
entende et cette promesse et cette
guerre contre le terrorisme
définie par bush à l'époque on se rend
compte que vingt ans après qu'est ce qui
s'est passé il ya eu cette guerre de
nécessité qui a été la guerre afghane où
l'amérique est intervenu pour chasser
ben laden et al qaïda et puis cette
guerre de choix des dirigeants
américaine qui était la guerre en irak
mais ces deux guerres ces deux
investissements ont mené à quoi un
retrait précipité d'irak en 2010 ce qui
permet l'émergence de dèche et
aujourd'hui on leur donne les clés aux
talibans exactement au même que vous
qu'on était venu chasser 20 ans avant on
peut se poser la question aujourd'hui à
ton gagner cette femme fameuse guerre
contre le terrorisme moi je crois que
non et justement je voulais vous faire
réécouter une phrase glace enfin c'était
en avril
2001 cinq mois avant ces attaques la
phrase évidemment été prononcée par le
commandant massoud écouté mon message au
président bush est le suivant les
problèmes auxquels nous faisons face
seront bientôt ceux des américains et du
reste du monde
lombardo plus que visionnaire commandant
massoud on se souvient de cette phrase
clairement on se retrouve aujourd'hui
dans la même situation vingt ans après
ce que cette phrase est toujours
d'actualité on pourrait la transposer
situation empire et empire d'après moi
pourquoi parce qu'il ya 20 ans il ya des
choses qu'on ignorait aujourd'hui on
sait certaines choses on sait par
exemple que l'on parle d'un gouvernement
d'un pseudo gouvernement fantoche des
talibans alors qu'il existe un
gouvernement légal en afghanistan la la
la la fuite de la fuite pitoyable de
ashraf ghani le président afghan n'a pas
me faire au gouvernement afghan le
gouvernement afghan légales existent
toujours la constitution afghane prévoit
en effet que en cas de vacance de la
présidence et le premier vice président
qui devient président jusqu'à preuve du
contraire les nations unies n'ont pas
reconnu des talibans et reconnaissent
toujours le gouvernement afghan dont le
président le rituel s'appelle andrew la
salle est ainsi chef des services
secrets de bassoul premier
vice-président dont nouveau président
qui combat les talibans aux côtés de
ahmad masood open cheer voilà ça c'est
la réalité donc moi je moi je suis
vraiment pessimiste je sais pas si mon
confrère aller ou pas mais moi je suis
extrêmement pessimiste parce que je
pense que nous nous référons exactement
les mêmes erreurs mais avec des
conditions aggravante parce que nous
savons aujourd'hui que la politique qui
a été menée en afghanistan contrairement
à ce que réclamaient le consommation
détruit nos politiques
l'élite littéralement meurtrière pour
les idées de démocratie que nous
prétendons
exportés vers vers l'asie centrale est
noté notamment vers vers l'afghanistan
ça c'est vraiment très important
pourquoi allons-nous commettre les mêmes
erreurs qu'il ya vingt ans pourquoi
n'avons nous pas entendu le commandant
massoud il ya 20 ans pourquoi le
président chirac et le et le premier
ministre lionel jospin refusait de lors
de le recevoir lorsqu'il est venu à
paris alors qu'il venait de recevoir des
ministres talibans et pourquoi
aujourd'hui dans la journée ou pas le
dialogue avec ahmad masood directement
pour moi ça me semble absolument une
cohérence ça me semble suicidaire
un modèle en régie rapide où je pense
qu'on assiste plus globalement
au désengagement des américains
certaines régions du monde là c'est le
centre de la vie bientôt ce sera à moi
j'en suis quasiment certain la zone
enfin le moyen-orient l'irak et la syrie
les états unis tourne aujourd'hui lors
de leurs yeux vers la chine et vers
l'extrême orient c'est pas nouveau ça
mais ce qui est ce que ça provoque ça va
être justement la montée en puissance
d'autres de puissance entre guillemets
régionales ou internationales mais avec
des velléités on voit les chinois sont
déjà ont déjà pris langue depuis très
longtemps avec les accès cette victoire
des talibans même avant qu'elle soit
effective donc il ya une neuro il ya il
ya une haute définition du monde dans
laquelle l'occident a nettement moins de
place les français on n'a plus tellement
voix au chapitre on peut toujours faire
des déclarations d'intention et autres
mais concrètement il y en a qui sont
déjà à la manoeuvre les turcs les
iraniens les pakistanais depuis
longtemps mais aujourd'hui on va les
chinois et les russes qui reviennent
voilà il avait quitté l'afghanistan ils
iraient la queue entre les jambes en 88
et aujourd'hui sont là à nouveau voilà
merci en tout cas tous les deux pour ce
débat intéressant passionnant salvatore
lombardo et régis le sommet merci à vous
deux
et d